- I recently told somebody that
getting attacked by a shark
was the greatest thing
that's ever happened to me.
And they're like, "That's absurd.”
“You know, why would you say that?"
I've had incredible opportunities.
I've been able to visit
some really cool places
and meet some incredible people.
All these things have been
nurtured from this shark attack.
I think it's really
made me who I am today.
(driving piano music)
My name is Mike Coots.
I live on the island of Kauai in Hawaii.
I'm a surfer, photographer,
and shark attack survivor.
There's some really great
surf spots out here.
I was 18 years old, surfing
here on Kauai with some friends,
and it was early in the
morning and I paddled out
and thought I was gonna
have a surf session
like any other day, and
it was a lot different.
I got attacked by a tiger shark.
As soon as I hit it,
it let go and disappeared back underwater.
And I remember passing out
basically as soon as
we got to the hospital
and I woke up a day-and-a-half
later an amputee.
I got my first prosthetic six
months after the shark attack.
Early on, you think you can't do this,
you think you can't do that.
You know, there's these physical
limitations on life.
And I didn't think I could drive
a truck with a stick shift.
And you learn how to drive
a truck with a stick shift
and you're like, "Wow, that was cool."
And you build up these little
things like day to day to day.
After a while, it's like bring it on.
What can happen that I
can't figure out how to do?
I was in college and I
remember class got out.
I was like, "You know what?”
"I'm gonna take a longboard;
I'm gonna get the
biggest board I can find
and just take my prosthetic in the water
and see what happens."
I caught a wave and I was
screaming pretty loud.
I was like, "What?!”
"This is cool; this is amazing!"
And I think that was the best wave
I had ever caught in my life.
From then on, I started figuring out,
okay, what's gonna break?
What can I make that's a foot
that'll help me surf even better?
And trying to basically make
the ultimate surfing foot.
I think I'm doing it because it's fun,
but I’m also, it's this learning experience
and it's taking this
information and passing it on
to people that wanna
surf with a prosthetic.
The ocean has taken a lot from me,
but what it's given back to
me has been immeasurable.
I've lost, you know, nearly my life to a shark,
yet I really believe sharks are one of the
if not the most important
species in our marine ecosystem.
And at the rate that
they're being killed off,
they're not gonna be
around in 10, 15, 20 years.
And why not use something that could,
I guess, be said as a negative
and turn it into a positive.
The shark attack's been the greatest thing
that's ever happened to me.
(slow pop music)